MATTEO VALLONE: For
whoever doesn't know me,
my name is Matteo Vallone.
I see many familiar faces.
I work with European
developers, and today I'm
going to focus on
engaging users.
First to start, can
you raise your hand
if you think that in
the last six months
you used every single app
that is on your phone?
All right.
Last month?
Last week?
Yeah.
All right.
I thought that.
These are very
important questions.
How many apps you
have on your phone
and how many you
actually use regularly
is the key question
for engagement.
And as a developer,
what you should
ask yourself is how many
people have installed
your app versus how many
have actually used it?
Installing an app
doesn't do anything
if the users actually
don't use it.
And you don't want to be
just a book on a bookshelf,
but you want to be the one
that users actually read.
So engagement is
critical, and regardless
of how you monetize
your app-- through ads
or through in-app
purchases-- you
want to focus a lot on this
key step of the user funnel.
We talked about
user acquisition.
We're going to talk about
conversion for developers that
actually monetize
through in-app payments.
But in any case, engagement
is going to be critical.
And it's sometimes overlooked
as a step in your product
development.
You have a big
challenge, which is
that users have many
apps on their phones
and on their devices
and not that much time
to use all of them.
And there are not very
clear lists of levers
that you can pull like you
have for user acquisition where
you have store discoverability,
cross-promotion, marketing, PR.
On the conversion
side you can do
discount, promo
codes, free trials.
On the engagement
side when it comes
to organic and free
solutions, it's
all about how you
build your product.
And you optimize it
for the key metrics
that actually matter to you.
It might be time spent.
It might be articles read.
Whatever matters
to you should drive
how you build your
product and optimize it.
And if there was
only one key message
that you could take away
from this presentation,
I wish it was this.
You should move being from
the model of just being
a dumb destination to
being a smart companion.
Installing the app on the device
shouldn't be just bookmarking
it on the home page.
That's a website.
An app is smart.
It's powerful, and it should
be always available to the user
when it matters.
It should be integrated
with a device.
That's installing.
And that means that
you're not building
just an homogeneous experience
that everyone lands to it,
but you're personalizing it.
And you're aware of what
is the context of the user
so that you can
anticipate their needs
and not just reacting to them.
And I'm going to talk
about few things you
can do to make sure you
really optimize your product
to be a smart companion.
So these are the key focus area
that I'm going to talk about.
They're all very relevant
and work together.
Integration through intents.
If you don't know what intents
are, I'll explain it soon.
But that's a way to integrate
your app in the operating
system within the
Android open platform.
Capturing identity and
context of your user,
very important to then
personalize and anticipate
their needs.
And using rich
notifications as a way
not just to communicate
with your user--
to reach out to your
users-- but actually
as an extension of your
UI into the device.
Into other devices as well.
And I'm also going to talk a
little bit of how this empowers
you to actually build the best
possible cross-platform user
experience while you
focus on the use case
and then build a UI for it,
instead of doing the opposite.
And being enabled by having all
these three pieces in place.
So I'll start by
talking about intents.
And first of all, if you
have an Android phone,
you already know
what intents are.
Basically, whenever you click
on a link or on an action,
sometimes you're presented
with a few options
of apps that can
perform that action.
And that's an intent.
That's basically leveraging the
power of intents on the phone.
And an intent is basically
a combination of an action
and a piece of data,
like scanning a barcode
or sharing "I love pizza."
The powerful thing is
that on Android, your app
can take care of an intent.
Like if you're building a
scanner app, then scanning
a barcode is what your app does.
But also you can
outsource tasks that
are not really relevant to
your app, to other apps.
So you're building, for
example, an e-commerce app.
And you don't want to
build a barcode scanner,
but you need a barcode to
be scanned at some points.
And you can call the
operating system at that point
and say, what is the app
that can do that for me?
And whatever app
is installed and is
declared in the
operating system that
can perform that task will
be presented to the user.
So that's why we call
intents basically the glue
between application components.
And it's what makes the Android
operating system so open
and enables apps to
talk to each other.
But that means
also, that you can
take ownership of an
action on the device
across the experience
of the users.
So you can offer your
service to other apps.
In the previous example, if
you're just barcode scanner
app, you're offering
every other app
that needs the service
of doing that for them.
In another example, if
the user is on a news app
and wants to share
an article, if you're
building a social and
communication app,
you can declare in
the operating system
that you can handle that
action, the sharing action.
And your app will be
automatically presented
to the user here.
These are not just Google Apps.
Any app can do it.
Again, that's why Android
is such an open platform.
So another example and another
very powerful one is with URLs.
You can tell the
operating system,
I can handle the intent of
opening that and showing
that URL.
Here is what Maps does.
No matter if I'm looking for
our office address on Search
or if Shannon sent me a link.
Whenever I tap on that, I will
be presented with all the apps
that can perform that task.
And in this case,
Maps can do it for me.
So I can skip the browser.
So even more than that,
if you think about it,
app indexing-- for who doesn't
know what app indexing is,
it's basically a way
to set up your app
to show the option to the
user within the search result
to open a link from the
search results within the app.
So it's basically the
organic, non-paid solution
of what Bruce described.
And that's enabled by intents.
Without intents, without setting
yourself up for this task,
you couldn't be able to leverage
the power of app indexing.
So if you are
interested in this,
you can look for more
details on this website.
OK.
So that's intents,
and that's how
you intercept user needs
as they present themself.
But you also want to
know more about your user
so you can anticipate
their needs.
And the set of information
you should think about
is not only the user
preferences and the user history
but also what comes from
the device they're using.
Not only the screen
of the device,
which might inform what type of
experience they are looking for
but also what time
of the day it is.
Where they are.
If they're moving
fast, sitting down.
Whatever is relevant
to inform the way you
can tailor the best
possible experience.
But in order to
do that, you need
them to sign in at some point.
And the key thing here
is that on mobile, it
is even more painful
than on laptops
to sign in because you
don't have a keyboard.
And a mobile device is
supposed to be more immediate.
It's supposed to be about
the content, soon and fast.
So one very important
thing to make sure
that your user actually
sign in and you
can get all information you need
is to make it easy for them.
And here Guardian
is a great example
of integrating all the important
third-party signing services
and how this makes it
more easy for users.
And by way, 41% of users sign
in through the Google Sign
In method, and that's a very
common thing on Android.
We see that a lot,
Google being one,
if not the most,
popular sign in method.
That's because every
Android user is already
signed in with a Google
account on the device,
on the Play Store.
So they don't need to input
any username, password.
It just works-- seamless.
That's one thing,
making it easy.
But you shouldn't
take it for granted.
You should probably treat
signing in as a transaction
and identity as a currency.
Like you pay a lot of attention
in converting users from free
to paid users, you shouldn't
take signing in for granted.
They're basically
trusting you to use
their personal information the
right way and protect them.
So you want to make sure that
the onboarding experience is
the best possible and
that you're leading them
to the point where they're
comfortable signing in,
and they understand the value.
Again, The Guardian is
a great example of that.
You can browse all the
contents and read articles.
But when you want to start
personalizing the experience
by liking, bookmarking
or sharing an article,
then you need to sign in.
And then you
understand that that's
the step you have
to take to do that.
And in that context,
they also tell
you more about why and the
full value of signing in.
You can be more
aggressive than that.
You can limit experience
to few contents,
few articles, few features.
But you want to make sure
that the user can enjoy
your app before asking
them to sign in.
This is very, very
important-- especially
as mobile becomes a user
acquisition tool and not
just an extension of whatever
you offer on the web.
OK.
Third point is
rich notifications.
Ellie already talked about this.
And it's very clear
that notifications
are very, very powerful
tool on Android.
Here you see an example of why.
You have very rich content
you can show to users already
in the notification framework--
text, picture, actions.
Very important.
You can ask users to take
actions outside the app.
They can open your app
without opening it.
It's an extension of your UI
into the operating system,
into the device.
And even more, you can
customize that experience.
Here is an example of the
Play app-- Play Music app
where it allows you
to control a song that
is playing in the background
through the notification.
So very powerful.
And with the introduction of
Wear, it's even more powerful.
Again, this concept of extending
your UI into the operating
system is even
more powerful when
there are more devices
and, like Wear,
where it's all about using a
notification in a smart way.
Here are good examples of what
Facebook, Lift, and Runtastic
did.
You can add also actions that
are only relevant to Wear,
but any notification will come
for free on the Wear device.
You can then optimize it,
and make it more relevant.
But with great power comes
great responsibility.
You don't want to overdo.
You won't want to scare
users, to become spammy.
That will mean that probably
the user will turn notifications
off or, even worse,
uninstall the app.
So here are some
guidelines on how-- first
of all, when to
show notifications--
and how to show them.
The main thing is-- again,
back to identity and context.
You want to capture
information that
are relevant to build the
best possible experience
for your users.
And this is very important,
personal, time sensitive,
relevant to context.
But also how you present them.
I just want to
highlight the last one,
stack your notification.
Key.
Six emails here in
one notification,
very nicely presented.
If you have six notifications
from the same app here,
it very quickly becomes scary.
And a scared user would
probably not be very engaged.
So very important
to pay attention
to how you do it because
it's very powerful.
And here I wanted to
show you another example.
Here is Any.do
using notification
as an extension of their UI.
They also do widgets, so
the combination of both
made them achieve a
very important goal
so that 40% of their
users don't actually
open the app through the
icon on the homescreen
but through these extensions.
So, if you, please.
OMAR PERCHIK: Hey, I'm Omar.
I'm the founder
and CEO of Any.do.
Any.do is the world's leading
task management application
for mobile devices.
Our mission is to turn
every day into a good day
through creation of day-to-day
simple, beautiful, and fun life
management applications.
Creating an app
is not just having
an icon on the
user's homescreen.
It's about creating engagement
and getting the user
to use your app from
different parts of the OS.
That's why we integrated
our app deeply into the OS
and created different
ways for the user
to interact with our app.
In most cases, people think
about opening an app just
through the icon.
But in Any.do's case, we've
deeply integrated into the OS
in several ways.
The first way was to
integrate with widgets.
In the widgets, you can
actually see all of your tasks
that you have planned for
today, tomorrow, upcoming,
and someday.
But you can even mark
them as complete.
So just by clicking on one
of the tasks, you can choose
and you can mark
them as complete.
The second type of integration
that we did in the active part
was to actually, in the
notification center,
show all the tasks that
you have planned for today.
And you can easily
scroll between everything
you have planned
or add a new task.
We've seen that over
40% of our users
open the app not
through the icon.
Which means that the integration
with the OS on the deepest
level provides a lot more
engagement than anything else.
So to sum up, the
Android platform
allows us to do a lot
of things in order
to increase users' engagement.
We've managed to create an
experience in which the app is
so deeply integrated to
the device, where you'll
feel as if it's part of the OS.
This allows us to
create a great user
interface, a great
experience, and a better usage
from our users.
Thank you, Android.
MATTEO VALLONE:
They were basically
repeating exactly what
I said, but better--
in two minutes
instead of 30 minutes.
Using notifications
to extend their UI
and driving engagement.
Again, very important impact.
Now 40% of their users
actually open the app
not through the icon
on the home page
but through this other means.
They have a notification where
you can look at your tasks
and check them or
add stuff-- again,
in the notification framework.
So very powerful.
To wrap up, I just wanted to
talk about the cross--platform
experience.
That is very
important, and Ellie
has talked about this a lot.
How does things
come into place when
you think about your
cross-platform experience?
First of all, the
important thing
is that you shouldn't build
your UI first and then
adapt it to the device.
We're building in
an ecosystem that
is so rich that it will
allow you to think of the use
cases that are relevant
to you and then understand
what devices support
them and what
are relevant to each use case.
If you have that approach, then
you're in the best position
possible to build the right
UI for the right devices.
But to do that, you have
to understand your users
and integrate with each
one of these devices.
So it's very relevant.
And a good example of
this is musiXmatch.
For who doesn't know,
musiXmatch is a great app.
It's a lyrics app.
It lets you play songs
that are on your device
through their player, and
it shows you synced lyrics.
It also allow you to recognize
a song with the microphone,
and when the song is recognized,
it will show you synced lyrics.
And they thought about
all the use cases
that they could cover in
that, for that functionality
and how those different
devices apply to each use case.
So now they are on
phones and tablets
but also on TV through
Chromecast and on Wear.
And they have been
very successful,
but they wouldn't have
been if they weren't
ready positioned
to take advantage
of all the key features that are
available on Android to drive
engagement.
And all the things
that we talk about
are the things that
they have done.
And I'm not saying-- they are
a great example of driving
engagement through these things.
I'm not saying that just
because they're Italian.
I mean they are, and
that's very important.
But I just wanted to
show you an example
of how well they use
notifications and the context
aware example and also
how intents is key here.
So Play Music app here.
A user is playing a song.
They listen to an intent.
Every music player
sends an intent
to the phone of what
song is playing,
and they listen to that.
They recognize
the song, and they
send you notification-- very
personal, very context aware.
This is the song
you're listening.
I recognized it.
If you tap on that,
they open a widget
that overlays the Play Music
song-- the Play Music app--
and shows you synced lyrics.
You have opened the
app without opening it.
This is very relevant.
It is context aware.
You installed the
app, and now allows
you to do that even if you
forgot about musiXmatch,
Having done all of this--
launch this feature,
work on all the key
areas that we talk about,
and being available now
on all these platforms--
the last few months, it's like
three or four months, they
saw two times more
daily active users--
and we are talking about
millions of users here--
and four times more
streaming events, two
times longer average sessions.
So it really pays off to
focus on these things.
To wrap up, we talked
about intents--
how you integrate into
[INAUDIBLE] system,
anticipating user-- sorry not
anticipating, but actually
intercepting their needs.
And then how you can
capture identity and context
and leverage that to
anticipate those needs.
And use rich notification to
extend your UI outside the app
and how this allows you
to build the best possible
cross-platform user experience.
If you have questions,
I will be around.
You have my email.
If you don't, this is my email.
Send emails.
I will reply.
Thank you.